what is the maximum capacity of human
beings that can live
on earth
and
we can coexist and everything is
sustainable without it being you know
insanity what's the number nobody has a
clue well i think we do have a clue no
we don't you but how do you make a
formula but how do you if that's your
world it's to me if okay let's do basic
math formula what do you mean how do we
have a clue the way i would do it i
would say okay
where can't men live okay so maybe let's
just say percentage is a mountain
certain struggle you can't live in mount
everest you can take those mountains how
many square feet is that okay how many
square miles let's take this out okay
the world has so many total square miles
here's how many square miles we have
fantastic how much of it is water take
that out how much of it is this take
that out okay so we're really living
with this many square miles and then
what is a too congested is new york a
level of congestion healthy no what is a
healthy level of congestion how about we
do la la is congested four or five is
pretty bad but new york is horrible can
we do every city like new york no okay
but give me that formula anyways that if
every city in the world look like new
york city we can handle 22 billion
people i don't know but i know we can
figure out that mathematical formula so
then what that does to me is the
following here's what i do again purely
thinking like an analytics guy that's a
financial guy can you zoom into this
real quick for me
zoom in so the rest of the people
watching this as well can see it okay so
this go go a little bit more so we can
see it okay this is world population by
your go down city can see what the top
tom no no the other way where the tops
is what it is okay
world ometer world population by year
2020 we had around 7.794 billion people
okay
go down to when it was 3.7 million 3.7
billion okay so 3.7 billion was 1971
which is exactly 50 years ago was 3.7
billion go down to see when it was 1.9
billion okay stop 1927 what is the
difference between 1927 and 1971 that's
what 44 years that's exactly 44 years so
watch this it doubled in 44 years then
it doubled in
50 years so it dropped around 10 percent
15 a drop okay go down see
from 1.9 billion when it was a billion
okay one point no no one bill 1.9 okay
so it was a billion went 1804 to 1927 is
what holy [ __ ] that's 123 years okay so
it's crazy it took a long time to double
there between a billion and a half
billion was
1600 so that took how many years 196
years 250 billion is what
900 that's how many years 700 years keep
going lower keep going lower keep going
lower
so 900 if you go to you get the idea
what i'm doing with the math here at
5000 the bc before christ was 5 million
people so we went in the last 7 000
years from five million people
to eight billion people if i double that
if i double that here's what it looks
like let's double it let's play rule of
72. how many years is that seven
thousand years seven thousand years oh
let's double it so 5 million goes what
10 million 20 million 40 million 80
million 163 20 640 one two uh 1.28
billion 2.56 billion 5.12 billion 10
billion that's 11 doubles okay 10
doubles is what we're looking at it took
10 doubles only to go from 5 million
people
to 8 billion people
in 7 000 years okay
that to me i sit there and i say the
following i say
al gore is full of [ __ ]
i say aoc is definitely full of [ __ ] the
end of the world is in 12 years full of
[ __ ] but guess what
it is happening eventually if we don't
do something about it the end of the
world not the end of the world the end
of human population growth the the end
of the capacity what our capacity will
be so
then we can think like dr evil i can
tell you one thing that explains why
there went from 4 billion to 8 billion
for example why it's called the haber
bosch process it won two nobel prizes in
the early 1900s
it was a formula a technological uh
process
involving very high heat and very high
pressure an extremely complicated
process which was able to combine
nitrogen from the atmosphere
with natural gas to make ammonia
that ammonia is the basis of all the
nitrogen fertilizer being used in the
world's agriculture today it results in
at least a doubling of crop production
and that is why we see this news today
about sri lanka banning
nitrogen fertilizer and netherlands now
basically banning much of the nitrogen
fertilizer and this is the biggest
threat we have right now to an immediate
starvation situation in the world food
shortage you hear it said that's where
i'm going the odd time yeah but the
reason it's it's self-inflicted this
food shortage
nitrogen the air has 70 percent of the
air is a nitrogen we could take nitrogen
out of the air for the next million
years and make fertilizer because it all
goes back into the air again eventually
same with the carbon dioxide
we talk about ourselves emitting all
this carbon dioxide
what are we emitting it from oh fossil
fuels oh where did they come from
they came from life absorbing carbon
from the atmosphere as carbon dioxide
and being deposited in sediments called
oil gas and coal so when we put co2 in
the atmosphere we're just putting it
back where it came from in the first
place that's why co2 was so much higher
in the atmosphere in past millennia like
it's gone from 2500 ppm to 180 ppm 20
000 years ago
in 150 million years that's a long time
but it's been a steady downward trend of
co2 in the global atmosphere for 500
million years
there's been a couple of dips and ups
and downs but basically it's a downward
trend and that's because the carbon
has been taken from the atmosphere as
carbon dioxide which is the only way
life can get carbon it's the only source
of carbon for life and all life is
carbon based that's why they call it the
chemistry of carbon organic chemistry
and the chemistry of all other elements
in organic chemistry
so what we've got here is a situation
where people just don't understand that
there is no historical relationship
between the level of co2 in the
atmosphere and the temperature of the
earth so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here